today we're pushing the brand new
pumpkins smash bracket into its extreme
limits and show you all the amazing
things that it's capable of so guys we
have just launched a new pongfinity
racket the pongfinity smash we're really
excited about it let's smash it okay
let's move on to the first Challenge and
that is to see what items we can smash
reviews
[Music]
Ah that's a perfect size
this might be the one where it stops but
luckily I have the smash racket which
makes everything smashable Next Level
the classic wine glass
yeah I'm just warming up
got it the champion of the glass we have
something a bit harder next who goes
first
not a promising start
it's it's gonna pop to it is it
well we're gonna break I feel like it's
just getting stronger we've found
something at the smash racket maybe
can't do
Infinity smash bracket it looks golden
but only costs 39.90 let's smash it what
a sound
I broke the ball switch
up to your turn
we're trying a new tactic
the ball feels even stronger now I think
we're defeated by the light bulb but at
least we made a scratch
so the punk finish smash is perfect for
beginning players but let's see what we
can do with it
[Music]
oh
that was a good run this good grip you
don't need to lift the ball so much
[Music]
so could control even on those shots
really good chops it's very good for
attacking too like good control
attack Ethan
you can't miss
[Music]
nice nice I'm like honestly surprised oh
well you can play with this yeah why are
you surprised we made the racket
[Music]
by the way does any of you guys need a
new racket I don't have a racket you
want to try it yeah try some Top Spin
that is good
nice nice it's very good for top spins
like that no
[Applause]
no you are the first person in history
to own a pongfinity smash racket
come on you can do it come on
if you're starting you want to start off
with something basic that's the perfect
racket for you thank you and to
celebrate the launch the first 1000
smash brackets will be in great with the
number for one to one thousand be quick
to order if you want one of the limited
editions what can we catch with the
smash rocket if I have some surprise
objects for you Emma throw them on ping
pong ball level one
catch level two
[Music]
oh there we go level three yeah I'm
setting you three soon
[Music]
oh no is that your phone it's my phone
oh if Emma can catch this go
oh okay the next one you have no worries
of breaking because apparently it's
indestructible
[Music]
I told you it won't break surprisingly
good control for catching stuff as well
on to the next test we have different
trick shots let's see how well we can do
them with the smash rocket
I only need one try apparently the smash
racket is perfect for whatever that shot
is called
it's chopping approved as well
[Applause]
that was good foreign
[Music]
okay one out of one
two out of two
that's called the under smash
next we're trying to do the snake shot
we have the snake monster me cow corner
okay
monster Adam Barbara would be proud can
we use the racket as a hammer are you
using that technique
oh oh this is a good one
I mean it does work but yeah
at the bottom it's working
on to the next one I have a kayak but I
didn't paddle luckily I always bring two
smash brackets and the stick we're gonna
make our own
run away
see you actually really good he's gonna
go and live under the bridge if you're
sub boarding you can also build yourself
your own smash paddle well you went
quite fast you can say it's it's kayak
proof I wonder what Meek and Emil are
doing with the semester I guess right
now uh I have no idea smashed potatoes I
gave him a bit too much force that's the
first smashed potato
yeah and smash
yeah a bit of olive oil salts I just
smash them in the oven for about 20
minutes oh they're actually looking
quite good reviewing the pongfinity
smashed potato
hmm oh
nice
this might be the best potatoes I've
ever eaten you can try this recipe at
home definitely just get yourself a
pumpkin smash bracket because that's a
secret ingredient
can the Sensei smash the pinata
don't come near me go for it so sorry
for the pinata
[Music]
no it's not even falcon
ah what's inside a racket case a new
Racket and pumpkiny balls you managed to
break all the balls we have a special
campaign to start with a package of
pumpinity balls a racket case and the
brand new Smash rocket for 59.90 it
won't be destroyed by the Sensei when he
gets delivered don't smash it if you're
among the first 1000 to order it it will
come as an exclusive numbered batch
smash smash smash smash poke smash